was this a game it was a game before the
movie that was
it i mean it's cool but it's about as
basic as it goes
that's so crazy because it's like
they're animating with math if that was
red
it would be the goriest thing ever are
they just rotoscoping different things
and just cutting it out and having light
in it through it
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get a free trial of skillshare
premium membership
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
today we have an extra special episode
it's the tron versus tron episode hey do
you guys know why it's called tron
because it's north
north based on the game north but they
lost
the rights at the last second
but they made the name backwards and
they totally absolved them all legal
issues
yes sam any guesses as to why it's
called tron uh it's probably an
abbreviation for some like 80s
computer joke yeah it's an abbreviation
for some 80s computer jokes such as
electronic
yeah back when like electricity was
novel
and now we're gonna jump in and digitize
ourselves into the tron world just as
jeff bridges did back in the 80s
i've never seen the first tron movie
really what do you think of these
computer graphics
are these computer graphics these are
computer graphics see that's what that's
what i find kind of
confusing about this because this is
actually before cgi
but is that not cgi that looks this is
cgi that's what i'm saying this is
before the stained glass man that was
essentially the first cg character so
these are not
cgi shots that you'd normally kind of
consider but they are still generated by
a computer
i mean this is definitely 100 cgi okay
yeah that is absolutely
anytime you're seeing a grid or those 90
degree turns
i would have been blown away as a kid
watching this like the coolest arcade
coolest design great intro what about
that oh no i'm totally into this still
[Laughter]
so this is interesting there's a lot of
real plate elements of people here
being composited into cg background it's
like the people are the worst part of it
in a weird way because like everything
else is pretty crisp
and there's some cool aesthetics going
on
tron came out 1982 this is like kind of
pre-computers i mean computers are
around obviously they're doing cgi and
tron but it's definitely very
fast and loose with like the idea of
what like the computer aesthetic is
so the thing that's definitely catching
my eye first are all of their suits
are emitting light in kind of an
interesting way now of course these days
you'd have like el wire but
sure they didn't have that back then or
el strips maybe they could have done
like the reflector kind of trick where
you put reflective material
or something on your clothes and you can
put a light next to the camera and so
suddenly everything just gets
illuminated
if they weren't trying to also composite
them on cg backgrounds
they could have possibly gone that route
they didn't go that route they didn't go
that route well how did they make that
wait hold up is that a real set is that
a real set that's a real set
so how are they doing all of these light
effects then are they just rotoscoping
different things and just cutting it out
and having light emit through it
it's like a weird combination so what
they ended up doing is they filmed
people wearing black and white costumes
on a black background they used kodak
kodilith film which is a hyper contrast
black and white film and then you can
invert that
and the black stripes would end up
becoming white and then you could
backlight that throw a gel on the camera
and get glowing lines that lined up
the problem is you had to cut out every
single frame by
hand for the silhouette of the person
and then you also need to have the
background in a separate plastic not
only that they also did a face hold out
so they could brighten the faces
and they did an eyes and a mouth hold
out so the eyes could stay
white and the teeth could stay white so
literally for every single frame
when people are in the world of tron
there is a person have to go through and
cut out the person
cut out the eyes cut out the mouth cut
out the face
for every character on screen by hand
that sounds like some of the most
tedious work
i've ever heard about rotoscoping back
in the day
this tank has phong
long shading i mean think about it it's
like this is back in the days of
polygons
i hate to correct you this is
pre-polygons
okay wait pre-polygons are we talking
like primitives
kind of they had to go to different
computer companies and each company had
their own
software and their own computer for
rendering and they all worked
differently
so syd mead the famous sci-fi artist had
designed these really cool
motorcycles and the company that was
tasked with making them the way their 3d
program worked is they only had
certain primitives that were built into
the program but that means that you
couldn't design your own shapes
whereas another company could have you
actually design a mesh
but you can see that those flying tank
things they're all made out of like
basic primitive shapes
it's pretty interesting because like
some companies could render like solid
shapes
others were more like wireframe based in
fact there's a really cool way that they
did wireframes if we look at when jeff
bridges gets sucked into the computer
i'm warning you you're entering a big
error flynn
i'm gonna have to put you on the game
game you want games
[Music]
dude bounding boxes dude but then he got
he got meshed this is how we make 3d
models these are polygons
well it's removing him polygon by
polygon
digitize jeff bridges
wow oh it's a kaleidoscope i think i
know how they did that
snap tetris blocks this is what i'm
talking about with the opening credits
and this like this is great
this hasn't aged today in my opinion
this is something that could come out
today
and stand on its own merit of
stylization you know
[Music]
was this a game it was a game before the
movie i don't know if it was before the
movie it definitely was the game after
the movie this reminds me of snake
this is like competitive snake
[Music]
oh that shock wave was cool did you see
the occlusion of the cave crack
going into the distance there yeah and
the tires
so the scene it's a totally functional
scene right it tells a story there's
motion to it there's logic what we're
totally taking for granted is that the
scene is animated it's computer graphics
but they're animated computer graphics
when it comes to animation back then
there weren't tools for
animation you could build a scene and
you could put things in the scene you
could set them in the scene but that's
all you could do
you just set things in the scene here's
how they had to do it so there's six
numbers
you need to animate an object you need
its position x
y and z space then you need its yaw role
and pitch
so six numbers three numbers for the
rotation three numbers for the position
six degrees of freedom so the animators
literally had to sit there
and draw out on a piece of paper not
unlike a spreadsheet the spreadsheets
don't exist it's literally written down
by hand they'd have to go through and
enter the values for all six of those
numbers for every object
per frame so like just 100 frames of
animation for one object
is 600 numbers you have to go through
and punch in and you can't watch it
until it gets rendered out exposed onto
film and then screened that's so crazy
because it's like they're animating with
math
without any visual cues can you imagine
like having to do a cg render but it's
like okay i rendered it now i have to
wait three days for the lab to come back
with the film exposure
or it's like sir i have an idea for a
shot and you hand over this piece of
paper with all these numbers
and he goes there it's like hmm this is
really nice that's a cool idea maybe you
should go that way
[Laughter]
so it's kind of funny apparently we lost
subscribers
recently and i think it's because
everyone accidentally subscribed to
corridor digital.com our website where
you can get everything ad free and merge
discounts and exclusive shows
the thing is it's okay it's okay just a
reminder resubscribe
we'll be all set thanks i find myself
being surprised at how much computer
stuff did go into this movie there's
some live action
stuff here shot of the people but as
you're saying each person is rotoscoped
out so the background
is 100 created from scratch whether
through digital means or cartoon style
drawing means or whatever optical
effects to create that sort of
background look
the people are the only things that are
captured for real which is kind of
interesting when you compare that to the
most
recent tron movie tron legacy
the aesthetic is an interesting thing
when they're working on the second movie
because
they couldn't just replicate the effects
of the first movie because computer
graphics had come
so far since then and people's
expectations for computer graphics were
at a much higher level
but if they strayed away too far from
the overall aesthetic people would say
it's not tron anymore so they had to
like kind of find that balance
i think they'd managed to do a pretty
good job of emulating the
style of the first movie while giving
everything a significant upgrade and
visual appearance
[Music]
that's a sweet effect
that was it i mean it's cool but it's
about as basic as it goes
i mean it's pretty sweet i liked it but
it looks nice but it's no freaking
flying into the air getting frozen and
de-meshed yeah i mean the other shot was
literally like a ground-breaking shot
wow there it is there's the same u-haul
boat once it was rectangles and
triangles
and now look at it a lot of this movie
is cg but unlike the first movie
they filmed a lot of stuff practically
on real sets with real costumes and kept
the majority of that so they got to have
lights in the suits for this one
they did digital scans of the main
actors and
took those scans of those people and
built the cg suits around them
to be fabricated specifically for those
people and then they're able to weave in
all these light designs
it's interesting seeing this like wide
city shot after looking at the original
tron
immediately there's like technological
things that stand out to me everything
from
volumetric clouds to reflections to
motion blur
to things being out of focus so i think
reflections and refractions
that was probably one of the biggest
challenges of this movie something that
this movie did that the first movie did
not was
film everything in stereoscopic 3d which
means
a two-camera system you have one camera
pointed forward here and then another
camera
pointed through a mirror slightly offset
to give you that inner pupillary
distance of your eyes
for a 3d movie and you know that's
already a challenging task but when you
throw in the fact that every surface
you're looking at is going to give you a
slightly different reflection and almost
everything you're looking at is a
reflective surface it's a monumental
task for not only the filmmakers but the
visual effects artists there's
definitely irony in the fact that
the set is real the costumes are way
more real but just so much more as
practical compared to the commitment
to like the first tron being an animated
film
[Music]
you know i think one of the biggest
things that like strikes me compared to
the original tron is that back then when
you did cgi
your cgi image would be your past and
that would be it you wouldn't then be
able to take that cgi image and add more
things like when you see crazy cg shots
like this it didn't come out of the
computer
rendered with all these effects in place
and they just drop the guy on top of it
and call it a day the lens flares the
glow probably even the motion blur like
all these extra little
bits and bobs to decorate it are added
after the fact it's not just hit render
get the pretty image call it a day but
back with the original tron
that was hit render that's what you get
call it a day
so obviously the light cycles got a huge
upgrade they have lights on them do they
have the trails in this movie yeah there
they go there's the trails and i love
the look of those trails that like
slightly transparent fined edges look to
them
the jelly glass jelly glass
i like how every time someone dies they
explode into like crazy
glowing neon liquid blocks yes it's so
satisfying look at this boom
and if that was red it would be the
goriest thing ever but it's not and so
it's super sweet
yeah so they were inspired by the first
movie's de-resin effect where anytime
someone dies they would kind of like
flash and then fade out but this time
around they decided to take that to the
next level and actually have the person
like disintegrate into these digital
cubes
the director had seen this commercial
and was like i like that effect
let's kind of do something similar to
that but for tron it's really cool
it's a houdini simulation where they
have the match moved person basically
just disintegrating into these little
digital cubes that just
splash out on the ground and then they
took that a step further for the cars
so the cars are actually filled with
liquid so when they
break up and explode you get like those
liquid simulations of splashing
magma flying around which looks really
cool that's super cool
it's really cool going and doing these
comparisons between an old film and a
new film that are in the same world if
there's any other comparisons that you
guys would like to see
whether it's like a classic film than a
remake or that's really all the options
there are
just the classic film and a remake so
yeah let us know
so comparing the neutron to the old tron
there's something that really stands out
to me and you mention it sam when it
comes to like the sets and the costumes
when you see that crazy shot
it kind of takes your breath away it
doesn't take your breath away just
because it looks cool it takes your
breath away because somebody
made it you see the craftsmanship and
the artistry and you can imagine
somebody sitting there
hanging all the lines and designing it
and in a way with how
good the visual effects got in the
second tron they're almost so
good that you lose that concept of
somebody being able to go out and make
it well here's the thing though the old
tron
it commits hard to hey we're in a game
engine we're in a computer this is
digital
and then in the neutron they're kind of
like we're going to set that aside for a
little bit here
and just go off on our own style here
you look at that it
doesn't feel like you're in a computer
anymore it loses that raw
feel of being on a circuit board with
your motorcycle
i feel like if they're gonna make
another tron movie making it feel more
retro
could probably pay off like the ultra
slick
design it's cool and all but where do
you really go from there
you're right make me a cool movie with
old-fashioned polygon style
art directions if you're trying to
recreate that light cycle scene i bet
you i personally could do that in like a
day
maybe a day and a half which is crazy
honestly i feel like i could pump out a
chunk of this whole scene in an hour i'd
agree if you guys want to see us try to
recreate some shots from the original
tron and like document the process
uh let us know in the in the comments
below we'll give it a shot here in a
video
hey what's up so everyone here at
corridor we all have different jobs we
all have to wear different hats
and each of those jobs require different
skill sets and sometimes it's a bit of a
challenge to learn those skills so
thanks to the
sponsor skillshare is easier than ever
to expand your knowledge
skillshare offers classes that are
designed for real life you know like
real practical things not just like
video and editing and photography but
like marketing as well
you know all kinds of different classes
exist for the real world needs that you
might be facing
for instance i really enjoyed the course
from kevin kennedy on how to use fusion
360. it's a 3d modeling program if you
want to do like 3d printing and stuff
like that he teaches you everything you
need to learn how to use the program in
just 30 days
an example of a real life application i
was able to apply those skills to a real
life project in my nerf drone video
skillshare is also incredibly affordable
an annual subscription will only cost
you 10
a month for everything you could
possibly want to learn
and guess what the first 1000 people to
click the link in the description
will get a free trial to the skillshare
premium membership
hurry i bet there's gonna be a thousand
people clicking that link if you wanna
be one click it right now
if there's ever a place where investment
is worthwhile it's in your brain
and expanding that brain space to be a
galaxy sized brain
so you know jump on your learning today
you know how it goes
there's so much there that we still
didn't even get to maybe we'll tackle
that stuff in another episode
at some point down the line but for now
thanks for watching i really appreciate
you tuning in
and i'll see you next week in another
episode of filmmaking people crew react
pas react to the best coffees at
starbucks
yeah you wanna get someone hit the outro
theme and call it yeah actually i
haven't seen
either of those movies was pretty cool
seeing some of these clips
have you really not seen them no i
haven't seen this i just
i haven't seen any movie we've done on
the show